youngstown ohio michael
is calling hey michael welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hi how are you better than i deserve
what's up
i'm calling i'm on baby step number two
and i'm calling to see if it changes
anything
um based on the fact that my my car loan
is
zero percent interest nope
okay you list your debt smallest to
largest regardless of the interest rate
is this debt snowball
pay minimum payments on everything but
the little one and attack the little one
this is not an interest rate problem
you're going to pay off all your debts
very very quickly and interest is really
not going to factor into it for that
reason
very much how much debt have you got
total
um 98 000 including my home
okay how much of that's your home i'm 68
000.
okay so you have 30 000 in baby step 2
how much of that is car
um pretty much all of it eight hundred
dollars
on a credit card i can pay that off
what's your household income
um i make around 50 60 000 a year uh
depending on overtime and bonuses
and you have a 30 000 car debt
yes well probably need to sell the car
actually when you own things with wheels
and motors
that total up to being more than half
your annual income
it's very very difficult to prosper
financially
because thirty thousand dollar cars turn
into eight thousand dollar cars in about
an
eye blink and when you lose that much
money making sixty grand
it's tough to recover so you probably
have a car you can't afford is your
income going up
pretty steadily and fast and you're
gonna pay this car off really really
fast
within the next within the next two
years i'll be making
over a hundred thousand dollars okay
then maybe we keep it but you're gonna
have to lean into it and knock it out i
want it gone and
let's see ought to be gone in here you
need to be debt-free in a year
2 500 bucks a month 2500 a month beans
and rice
rice and beans chop the card up get rid
of the car
and so if you're going to keep it you
need to pay it off real fast
and the only reason i'm saying you could
keep it is because you're going to be
making 100 and driving a 30 000 car paid
for
making 100's okay driving a 30 000 car
making 57 000
really not okay it's not smart and so
it'll get you
you know it's just a matter of can you
afford to take the hit
the depreciation the sound of money when
you go across the
curb into the street from having bought
a new car cha-ching it just went down in
value